let's talk a little bit about the
israeli-palestinian conflict and
golden-boy son-in-law of donald trump
Jared Kushner husband of Ivanka Trump to
reset the backstory for you on the
israeli-palestinian conflict in case
you've forgotten Trump campaigned on I'm
gonna solve the israeli-palestinian
conflict and you at the time might have
wondered wait people who actually know
about the conflict and understand the
conflict have been unable to solve the
conflict why is it Donald Trump who
knows nothing about it is going to be
able to solve it well part of trumps
reasoning was that Jared Kushner his
son-in-law and ambassador David Friedman
were going to be able to solve the
entire thing now the reality has been
the exact opposite of that Jared Kushner
completely incompetent data Friedman the
last person who should be involved in
that discussion he actually said at one
point that he believes there should be
more Israeli settlements and was a very
loud voice in the push for moving the US
Embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem in
recognizing Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel all terrible ideas and from very
early on in this administration Jared
Kushner was involved in shaping policy
around the Middle East related to the
israeli-palestinian conflict in fact
when Trump went on that first
now-infamous
diplomatic trip to Israel and other
parts of the Middle East Jared Kushner
was right there because he was Trump's
guy I guess in the area we've now
learned through very good reporting by
the New York Times that just before that
trip right just before Jared Kushner
went with Donald Trump to the Middle
East to be involved in negotiating
American policy there Kushner's family
real estate company received thirty
million dollars from menorah meeting
which is an insurance company that
happens to be one of Israel's largest
financial institutions maybe a conflict
of interest now the thirty million
dollar deal was not public it added new
equity to ten Maryland apartment
buildings that Jared Kushner's company
controls so let's break down what is and
what is not with regard to this thirty
million dollars
number one I'm not saying nor is there
evidence that this was illegal okay the
law is actually really really narrow on
this and it doesn't seem that federal
ethics laws were violated by this it
doesn't appear nor am I suggesting that
Jared Kushner personally negotiated the
thirty million dollar deal but Kushner
knows he has a stake in this business he
knows that he will make a bunch of money
from this deal so what I am saying is
that this could be the most biased and
partial group of people involved in the
negotiation of the israeli-palestinian
conflict to the extent that there's
actually any negotiation going on and
it's unclear that there is and to go
back to the very beginning the story
from Trump was we are going to fix the
israeli-palestinian conflict Jared
Kushner and David Friedman are going to
negotiate and the u.s. is going to be
the referee the arbiter of solving the
israeli-palestinian conflict to be an
arbiter or at least to be a potentially
effective arbiter there needs to be some
credibility to the idea that you're not
coming in as a biased party in the
negotiations it's like the referee in a
sporting event you need an unbiased
person calling the fouls we know that
Trump's ambassador David Friedman has
the position of wanting more settlements
by Israel in the disputed territories
it's an outrageous and extreme position
and it immediately signals him as not a
credible arbiter we know that Donald
Trump's decision to recognize Jerusalem
as the capital of Israel when in fact it
is still a disputed territory in the
conflict it's completely partial to the
Israelis and there could be no better
proof that the United States cannot be
an unbiased arbiter of peace talks in
the israeli-palestinian conflict and now
sort of the cherry on top we've learned
that Jared Kushner's family businesses
are profiting from doing business with a
major Israeli financial company and he
pat is going to be the guy who solves
the israeli-palestinian conflict it's
absolutely laughable and there have been
so many moments where we've wondered why
isn't just Jared Kushner resign right
because he got caught lying for his
national security clear answer maybe
when like the Don junior Natalia vessel
nice guy
news broke about that meeting in Trump
Tower he was involved in we thought we
thought you know he could probably lead
with some sort of grace he could resign
and because he's part of the Trump
family he could go to the family
business he could work with the Kushner
family again
now we realized that it's not because he
doesn't to be embarrassed so much as
that he's profiting from this presidency
he doesn't need to leave the White House
in order to keep working for the family
business and we we I mean another part
of it might be
according to Michael Wolf's book fire
and fury Ivanka and Kushner know the
deep you know what that they're in but
that they feel that they just can't
leave like in other words that because
of their in completely completely
intractable positions in that Trump
administration and they have to be there
anyway if you're gonna wait around
hoping that there's consequences to
Jared Kushner for being involved in this
forget it right I mean former Vice
President Dick Cheney was directly
involved with Halliburton financially
which supplied the American military he
pushed for war in Iraq a war that
greatly enriched Halliburton there were
no consequences there's not gonna be any
consequences here
yeah Donald Trump is pushing that tax
plan that ended up benefiting him
greatly yeah there's just never repr cut
there forget it if the idea is
repercussions and of course there's
always projection right is there
anything that Trump has accused Hillary
Clinton of doing that his administration
hasn't done he was accusing Hillary
Clinton of taking money from foreign
countries and foreign businesses and
here are Trump's own inner circle family
members doing the exact same thing it's
just politics as usual at warp speed
right that's what we're learning drain
the swamp was actually the opposite it
was filled of swamp
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on Twitter a David
Pakman show we'll take a quick break and
be back with more after this today's
program is brought to you by Skillshare
I don't know if you made New Year's
resolutions I tend not to and really try
to on a more monthly basis think about
where am i focusing my energy in one
place I'm increasingly focusing my time
and energy is learning new skills and
that's exactly what is made possible by
skill share which is an online learning
platform they have more than 18,000
classes business topics tech design and
more and whether your goal is just
to deepen your professional skill set or
maybe start a side business or just
learn something new for the sake of
learning new things Skillshare can help
you learn in 2018 and beyond and I took
their logo design class absolutely
fascinating and it's I'm just such an
uncreated person when it comes to
anything visual that to really go
through the process of learning the
building blocks of something like logo
design was absolutely fascinating for me
and the teacher for the class was also
really great but there's a limited time
offer from Skillshare for david pakman
show viewers and listeners three months
of Skillshare for 99 cents this is a
incredible deal 33 cents per month three
months 99 cents to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash Pakman 99 okay one
more time Skillshare comm forward slash
Pakman nine nine to get three months of
Skillshare for only 99 cents act now and
you can start learning today